foreign
it's a newer ephemeral version of Hot or
Not which is brilliant but I don't know
how protectable that is while I give you
total credit and I think you guys have
done some brilliant things I don't think
the risk reward is there for me and for
those Reasons I'm still out
good luck
thank you excellent presentation hello
and welcome to a new episode of RT
Essentials I'm Mark Ellis today we're
talking about TV and it's time to get
real as in reality TV the genre is only
a couple decades old but in that time
there's been some pretty Monumental
programs that have changed the face of
not only television but pop culture in
general from surviving to racing to
baking to selling to dating to just
plain living reality TV has covered a
lot of bases and introduced us to some
very interesting characters along the
way so let's pack up our things and move
in with complete strangers for a bit
metaphorically speaking of course as we
take a look at the best reality TV shows
Survivor Natalia need to bring me a
torch
[Music]
sorry
be sorry shut up
and kicking off this list with nothing
but the clothes on its back hopefully is
Survivor this series premiered on CBS on
May 31st 2000 as a summer replacement
show in it a group of Castaways are sent
to a remote destination where they not
only have to survive the elements but
also a game that sees a contestant sent
home every week but if you make it to
the end boom here you go million bucks
this series is the American version of
the international Survivor franchise and
is based on the Swedish program
Expedition Robinson which began in 1997.
the Swedish version is considered a bit
more mean-spirited so executive producer
Mark Burnett reworked the concept to
focus more on the human drama
experienced Under Pressure there's lots
of good news of the bad news bad news
bad news yeah I had no luck in the ocean
I was in the you broke the uh I didn't
break it it floated off while I was in
the swamp I wasn't using the mouthpiece
I was using this the mask
guys floated off so the the mouthpiece
is gone it is you couldn't find it it's
in the swamp there's nothing I'm gonna
do
and good news there are hundreds of
thousands of fish on their wreath so
the good news is you'll never believe it
there's fish in the ocean
survivor's been hosted from the
beginning by Jeff Probst who also serves
as an executive producer he went on to
win the Emmy Award for outstanding host
for a reality or reality competition
program for consecutive times after it
was introduced in 2008 after watching
with a roughly 75 person production crew
the series had grown to a crew of nearly
325 people by Season 22 in 2011.
Survivor is considered a leader of
American reality tv as one of the first
highly rated and profitable reality
shows on broadcast television in the
United States with its first 11 Seasons
ranking in the top 10 most watched shows
every year the series has over 60 Emmy
nominations Time Magazine added it to
their list of the 100 greatest shows of
all time in 2007 and TV Guide put it at
number 39 on its list of the 60 best
series of all time in 2013. the 43rd
season of Survivor premiered in the fall
of 2022 with no signs of its flame going
out anytime soon the real world come
back in my face and talk to me come back
in my face don't talk to me
I'm trying to talk to you like a man
David listen to me we've been trying to
leave for a half hour we were trying you
went for me for a half hour now let me
speak please we've been trying to leave
for a half hour we're trying to call a
cab you were on the phone we couldn't
call a cab what you know but eventually
when you calm down the next title is one
of ten shows picked to be on a list and
have their contents discussed that's
right it's the real world this series
involves seven or eight young adult
strangers who live in a house together
in a different host City every season
while being filmed Non-Stop and since
they can't use their mobile phones if
that technology existed at the time they
actually have to be face to face and
talk to each other and what we humans
used to call an interaction the houses
have been pretty cool in the core with
Ikea doing the Furnishing for many of
the seasons and usually has a pool table
and a hot tub and in many cases an
aquarium which is a metaphor for the
show itself the real world premiered on
MTV on May 21st 1992 where it aired
until 2017 becoming the longest running
program in MTV history the most recent
season aired on Facebook action 2019
with future seasons in development now
at Paramount plus who has produced a
couple of reunion shows from the early
Seasons my mom's saying that she's
coming the weekend after Easter and you
know the whole thing with my family is
you just can't believe it until you see
it because anything can fall through at
any second which could be good mom
you finally got here
you don't want to come here I already
feel like I'm in trouble
I told you that mothers the series was
notable early for depicting issues of
modern young adults at the time white
Prejudice religion sexuality AIDS
politics and substance abuse however the
show's reputation changed over the years
to be more of a showcase for young
people partying regardless it was a hit
for many years and cast members have
definitely taken advantage of the show's
popularity to launch their own careers
that includes Sean Duffy who was elected
to the United States House of
Representatives in Wisconsin as a
republican NFL Network stalwart Kyle
Brandt and of course Mike The Miz
missinin who is now a huge star in the
WWE The Real World also spawns sister
shows Road Rules and the challenge the
latter of which is an extreme
competition show with cast members from
both of those series which now has 38
Seasons under its belt RuPaul's Drag
Race today I'm wearing all the
rhinestones and baby I'm a star so
whoever come on that stage tonight much
much crunch crunch silky ganache is here
to eat the lunch
strutting its stuff next on the list is
the show RuPaul's Drag Race the
legendary RuPaul serves as host mentor
and head judge for this reality
competition series that is searching for
what they call America's Next drag
Superstar respective contestants submit
video auditions that are each reportedly
viewed by RuPaul who then selects the
cast the dozen or so Queens are given
different challenges each week and
judged on their performance with someone
usually sent home at the end of every
episode the prize for a winning
contestant includes a cash sum that has
climbed as high as a hundred thousand
dollars over the years plus a large
supply of cosmetics and naturally a
Bejeweled crown and scepter RuPaul's
Drag Race aired on the logo from 2009 to
2016 where it was the Network's highest
rated show before moving to VH1 with the
beginning of season 9. it also airs
International in places like Australia
Canada the Netherlands and Israel
I do have narcolepsy and the moment
where I'm most worried about my jokes my
body starts to shut down
[Music]
you might think I want to say jinx wake
up but sorry girl
this has become one of the most awarded
reality programs in any history
including RuPaul winning seven straight
times for outstanding host and the
series winning outstanding reality
competition program over four
consecutive years
the first series to win both of those
Awards in the same year which is now
done multiple times and RuPaul's Drag
Race was a launching point for a full-on
franchise including RuPaul's Drag Race
All-Stars and RuPaul's secret celebrity
drag race plus a number of online
companion series throughout the years as
well Top Chef for me the beauty of
eating creme brulee is that the sugar
glaze just cracks and you get that
crispy sugar I'm really missing that a
country a country with sugar over the
top is not creme brulee right I think
what's happened here is what's happened
throughout the meal a complete failure
of the imagination
I mean this four hours four hours
sharpening its knives and heading to the
next spot on this list is Top Chef this
series premiered on Bravo on March 8
2006 from magical elves Productions who
also brought us another show on this
list Project Runway this one features
anywhere from 12 to 19 chefs arriving in
a different city each season where they
compete in culinary challenges often
themed to and inspired by the location
they're judged by a panel of
professional chefs and other bigwigs
from the food and wine industry with the
winner taking home a six-figure sum of
Cash Plus other opportunities in that
world a Top Chef season also includes
what is known as restaurant Wars about
halfway through where they break into
teams and do pop-up restaurants and
beginning in season 9 eliminated
contestants have a chance to return to
the show by competing on a companion web
series called Last Chance Kitchen the
series has been nominated for an Emmy
for Outstanding reality competition
program 16 times winning once in 2010.
that success has resulted in multiple
spin-offs including shows like Top Chef
Masters top chef Just Desserts Top Chef
Junior Top Chef amateurs and Top Chef
family style it's really coincidental
that Ed couldn't find his pee puree I
didn't even know he was making a pea
puree Eddie I looked I couldn't find it
I'd have to say the dish that I really
loved was
Alex
they love the Pea parade I'm like this
is bull there's no way here that amount
of time I would never steal anything
it's not in my it's it's not even in my
thought process but it's not just more
TV shows that have come from Top Chef
and online culinary school Top Chef
University is available for monthly and
annual memberships and there's also been
a line of Top Chef branded frozen meals
I may have had a few myself plus a video
game challenging players to create the
best dish from items in a virtual Pantry
AKA reliving your 20s Top Chef was
renewed for a 20th season for 2023 where
they're gonna head to London and feature
past contestants from various
International versions of the show
that's actually going to be pretty cool
American Idol what happened I just
admonaged from waiting all day and what
just from waiting it's just well you
know the thing is you want to be in the
music business but you don't want to
wait to get into American Idol that to
me seems to be a problem and you know
for you to have a bad attitude about it
I think you're reading it too far no no
I'm not reading it too far because you
just told me that you were a little bit
annoyed that you had to wait three hours
to come in here and get your shot when
there are people that would wait years
to do so so I am now angry at you who I
don't like at all hitting the high note
next on our list of the best reality
shows is American Idol this show is
created by Simon Fuller and based on
another show he started in the UK called
pop Idol which in turn was inspired by
the New Zealand singing competition show
pop stars American Idol aired on Fox for
15 Seasons from June of 2002 to April
2016 and was revived on ABC in 2018
after a two-year hiatus each new season
begins with an audition round taking
place in different cities and usually
featuring a mix of potential finalists
interesting personalities and of course
the worst of the worst eventually it's
cut down to 24 or so contestants who
compete on the live shows with judge
critiques and the viewing audience
deciding everyone's fate each week via
voting
Stan I
don't sing no we said United
it wasn't great that they dog you not
ready for this level we're trying to
find the best we're trying to find the
best you weren't the best how are you
here honey we're not trying to hurt you
some of the most successful winners
include the first winner ever Kelly
Clarkson along with Carrie Underwood and
Jordan Sparks there's also an impressive
list of Nod winners that have gone on to
do big things like Chris Daughtry
Jennifer Hudson Clay Aiken and Adam
Lambert after the original judging panel
of Simon Cowell Randy Jackson and Paula
Abdul disbanded after spending the first
eight seasons together it's been quite a
revolving door of Judges since then
names like Ellen DeGeneres Jennifer
Lopez Steven Tyler Mariah Carey Nicki
Minaj and Keith Urban have filled the
seats while the latest panel includes
Lionel Richie Katy Perry and Luke Bryan
American Idol also put radio personality
Ryan Seacrest on the map who co-hosted
the first season with comedian Brian
dunkelman before taking over solo duties
in year two and never looking back back
for those keeping track of dunkelman at
home he did return for the finale on Fox
in 2016. this has become one of the most
successful shows in the history of
American television and not only because
of its impressive rating success and
accolades but through its cultural
impact in the music industry and pop
culture in general the Great British
baking show that moose is fine that
moves his mind I can't believe you've
given that to her that's mine that moves
give that back
I want to get my spatula in there come
on I did a little netball thing oh
that's mine whether I see it again
it's in the lap of the Gods huh that
delicious smell you're detecting could
be the next entry on this list the Great
British baking show this reality baking
competition series is known as the Great
British Bake Off in the United Kingdom
where it premiered on August 17 2010 on
BBC Two eventually moving to BBC One
after four seasons of increased
popularity the series features a group
of 10 to 13 amateur Bakers who compete
against each other in a series of three
rounds attempting to impress a group of
hungry judges with their baking skills
and avoiding the weekly elimination
ironically the show is conceived by
producer Anna Beatty after she had heard
about bake offs in America from a friend
and now lives come full circle it's back
over here thanks to Netflix and is a
global hit overall I'm a really really
really want to finish I haven't even
asked the bottom there yet I don't know
what to do are you all right Catherine
should I finish two tears what should be
the piracy what should be my priority
please excuse me finish two now no tip
no stop tears right come on melon suit
Melody hugging no tears but very brief
because you've only got a few minutes
[Music]
listen look you know what you've got to
do roll it out put it on and then get it
underneath amateur Bakers who apply have
to go through a growing audition process
that includes screen tests interviews
and eventually baking two recipes for
the judges in front of cameras but it's
well worth it as many of the winners and
participants from the series have gone
on to launch careers based in the bakery
business the Great British baking show
has been credited for regenerating
interest in baking throughout the United
Kingdom where stores notice the rise in
the sale of baking ingredients and
accessories and this bafta award-winning
show has spawned a number of specials
and spin-offs including Junior bake off
for younger children and Bake Off The
Professional for teams of pastry chefs
plus the format's been sold for use in
other series like the Great British
sowing bee and the great Pottery
Throwdown yeah you heard that right it's
a pottery Throwdown so I say bring it on
Project Runway no I'm painting no no
exactly I'm not forcing much I don't
think there is need for the extra time
that's gonna make this dress not look
good designers I'm just gonna get right
to it because we have the pleasure of
sitting next to one of the most revered
Beauties in the world my friend and your
guest judge Gigi Hadid
all right designers we all have our
scorecards and we are ready to start the
show walking with purpose to the next
spot on this list is Project Runway the
series was created by Eli Holzman also
known for his work on other popular
reality shows like project Greenlight
and Undercover Boss on this fashion
driven show designer contestants compete
with each other to create the best
clothes while being restricted by time
budget materials and a particular theme
a panel of Judges eliminate contestants
each week until only a few remain and
they prepare full-on collections for New
York Fashion Week with a winner chosen
after the runway shows the series
premiered on Bravo on December 1st 2004
where it aired for Five Seasons before
moving to Lifetime for 11 more seasons
and then back to Bravo in 2018 where it
currently resides Project Runway was
hosted by Heidi Klum until 2018 when she
and longtime show Mentor Tim Gunn left
for another fashion competition show on
Amazon she was replaced by model Carly
Kloss while season 4 went owner
Christian siriano replaced gun as Mentor
I need you to back up don't talk to me
like that the weak ones don't survive
everybody hates Atlanta
but there was one argument that is
clearly the biggest workroom fight in
history
this Series has picked up a number of
Emmy knobs throughout the years
including a loss to RuPaul's Drag Race
for best reality competition show in
2018. it also won a couple of awards
along the way including outstanding
hosts for Klum and Gunn in 2013. along
with over 30 International adaptations
the show also launched the spin-off
Project Runway All-Stars that ran for
Seven Seasons five of which were hosted
by Alyssa Milano and featured designers
from past seasons of this show there's
also a Wii video game launched in 2010
with plume and Gunn and a few
recognizable contestants appearing and
I'm not dusting out the Wii console for
that you know why it's already fresh I
play golf on it just about everything
The Amazing Race oh whose money is this
I just snatched naughty's hand and I
push it down and I'm like shut the hell
up not here you set it up here
when you find money like that a lot of
things are going through your head
you're wondering is this a game changer
reaching the checkpoint that is the next
spot on this list is The Amazing Race
this show usually features 11 or 12
teams of two who compete in a race
around the world the race is broken up
into legs with each one requiring teams
to decipher Clues navigate unknown areas
perform challenges and travel around
using Planes Trains and Automobiles and
so much more teams are eliminated at the
end of most legs with the winning team
in the end taking home a million dollar
prize it's just that easy everyone the
series premiered on September 5th 2001
on CBS and has been racing ever since
amazingly the idea came from husband and
wife creators Elise doganieri and
Bertram van Munster who had previously
worked on one of the earliest reality
shows ever cops if you got your shirt
off you're probably guilty this is where
we freaking put the pedal to the metal
we definitely pay extra good for fast
cabbies today guarantee you this could
be here right here go go go this is it
and we got the best cab driver in the
world right now and he's gonna bring us
to Candlestick Park
we went first there'd be all kinds of
breaking rodeos The Amazing Race has
been hosted by the Emmy nominated Phil
Keegan since the beginning a veteran New
Zealand television personality who also
serves as producer the show's visited
six continents sorry Antarctica keep
trying and nearly a hundred different
countries since its Inception with China
hosting the most pit stops thus far
followed by India and France so it's no
surprise the series has broadcast all
over the world plus a bunch of
international versions of the show had
been developed as well following the
same core structure it's not a bad show
to copy especially because it won the
Emmy Award for outstanding Rowdy
competition series 10 times out of its
19 nominations the series has moved
through time slots throughout the years
but is still consistently pulled in
about 10 million viewers per season the
34th of which just launched in September
of 2022 with I'm sure many more amazing
races still to come The Bachelor sorry
it's hard for me
I love it I do like I I do love you and
that's weird that I just said that
because I've been so terrified about
saying that
don't ever want to think about what it'd
be like to reveal
what
showing up on this list for the right
reasons of course is the bachelor this
dating and relationship series revolves
around a single Bachelor who Narrows
down a pool of romantic interest each
week ideally culminating in a marriage
proposal at the end of the season of
course a woman can withdraw at any point
if she's no longer interested in this
bachelor and with that a common source
of drama on the show is contestants
accusing each other of not being there
for the quote right reason and only
looking to further their own careers or
get you know free trips The Bachelor
debuted on March 25th 2002 on ABC and
was created by Mike Fleiss who also
created The Bachelorette and other
reality shows like Superstar USA and who
Wants to Marry a multi-millionaire the
series was hosted by Chris Harrison for
its first 25 Seasons with season five
Bachelor and former NFL Jesse Palmer
taking over for season 26 unlike many
reality shows the end results May Vary
with this one
I don't know
I could ever but
[Music]
other than I'm in love with somebody
else
[Music]
not only has the bachelor selected
neither of his final two women before
but on two separate occasions he has
broken off his initial engagement during
the after the final Rose episode and
gone on to propose and marry his first
runner up the weddings of the 13th and
17th bachelor's Jason mesnick and Sean
Lowe respectively were both broadcast as
television specials but of the 15
proposals through the first 25 Seasons
only Sean Lowe and Catherine Odysseus
from season 17 remain together as of
November 2022 they have three children
together of course those stats could be
improved as ABC renewed the series for
27th season in the spring of 2022. Shark
Tank I'm trying to not bite my nails all
the time where it falls down for me is
if I have the discipline to buzz myself
do I not have the discipline to stop
people okay people do you go to the
discipline to stop well I don't do you
wish you could stop I do so can I so
here's like your premises
Robert it's all nonsense across the
board and finally looking to make a deal
in the final spot on this list is Shark
Tank this show features budding
entrepreneurs who get their chance to
present their ideas to the Sharks AKA
Titans of Industry who turn their own
ideas into empires in hopes of finding
the same kind of success with one of the
Sharks as an investor the series aims to
capture the drama of real product pitch
meetings which is of course amped up for
TV if more than one shark is interested
in a product and a bidding Warren suit
Shark Tank was brought to air by
executive producer Mark Burnett
premiering on August 9 2009 on ABC it's
based on the international format known
as Dragon's Den which originated in
Japan and as a show called money tigers
in 2001 nearly 40 000 entrepreneurs
apply every season with only 150 Landing
in front of the Sharks and less than a
hundred making it to air this year we've
made 270 thousand dollars and how did
you sell those on our website your ask
is 212 000 for 10 correct yes why wasn't
it 200 or 225 212. do I know the real
answer that question yeah
lie to me no it's because I couldn't say
200 without stuttering so I had to find
a number that I could say without
studying because once I stuttered and um
the whole thing I'm gonna forget so
that's kind of why that's a great answer
you're an honest guy man I don't lie I'm
sorry one of the regular sharks Kevin
O'Leary has estimated that only about 20
percent of the handshake deals Seen On
TV are never executed after more
diligence is conducted but with that
said the show is responsible for what's
known as the Shark Tank effect where by
simply appearing in front of the Sharks
even without a deal you can
significantly boost sales for your
company some of the more notable
companies that have appeared on the show
include the apparel brand bombus Scrub
Daddy cleaning products Talbot teas and
the meal Service Company played it the
show has won multiple Emmys for
outstanding structured reality program
and in 2015 launched a companion series
beyond the tank catching up with past
companies that have appeared on the show
alright we did it the best reality TV
shows now that we've given you this nice
dose of reality which ones are you most
interested in re-watching or perhaps
checking out for the first time let us
know thanks for tuning in to RT
Essentials I'm your host Mark Ellis but
my friends just call me Joe Millionaire
[Music]
foreign